MIAMI AT 3:00
P.M. TUESDAYAN WILHES AGAINSTON
PLEA.TH
INME
CA THE CAMPAPO OCTNTRANDI KAYE N
TELL US WHAT
>> Rte INDICS WINGLY TAINED D
WILLFUL
INTE
GRPH 3 OF THS OUT VERY
RLKIND ON G
CAPABILITY.. WPOTEM,OG N
CAME FROM A VARIETRE, INTELLIGEE
THLUDEE A LARGY OFY
AT DONRUKICK SMITH REALLY UNDERS
RENCTO
CLXES OF ED DOCUMEN.RCH MAR-A-LF
THIS LAYE RR
WHAT THEY HAVE FOUNDS THEYOKD D
PRESI
FIED
DOCUMENTS, AND INDICTMENT.T SURI
ABN
INDICTME.
TALKING OU WITCTOR RE.
ITLLY ISN E'S NOT LO
JU LIKTHSEL
URGINGLLADLYHOE SO MANS., SED O
ACCUSED OF AEM
NTS WE WHAT UCK OU THE
B YAMA.
JUST TEV OLVEMENT
B.E 38 CLYMP.F
E INDICTMES DAMNING.
ITS
IN EVERY STE BOXES,  ECF
S,O DE XES NOT JUSTM THNT BUT F
SK ID THINFORMN NSONAGT,CTION L.
ITY BA
VOAND AUO IM
TETHAT AND
HAEVL THAT KEY
U  AD T.
UAT EG                   .UMP IS
COMMENTS TO HIS OW EVAN CORCORAO
MICHAEL N.
SO WHEE F  COMIN EN
CORCOR N NOT-- TE
CAD WITHOV TAS S VO
BEGINNG  IN ALE PAWHERTRUMP WAN
GHEML.ISS WHY HE RAN FOR  GOINGU
UP AND PUT YOU IN .
WANTS HISR E
HILLARY CLINT
>> THE AOVE EGALEA
ORYSLAAWAPRIL G INE ANY BEING
>> T JUS FINLAWYER WHOILHEE
INLO
I HS NOT ANTHE FIOF NATIONASERI
WEAWYERS AREISTS.
GOING AGAINST JAY BRE HEADE DEP
MEAREATHAT'S WHAS WICT WORK
REMEMBER THEOROUGH
THE EYD TRUMEN AN RETAINER.UMAD
TRP .IT DOESN'T HELTHAT INS  UT
WI ATTAC IE FUTURE.
NOT HELPWHOU'RE  HIMN YOU  IAL,N
WA
TRAIL.GRVA.AT'S WT POWERS MAGA..
FOR HIM NOT TO BE ABLE TO ATTACO
BE HARD FOR HIM AT COULD BE THEA
Y VIOLATINT ORDER. N
O DAYS FROM NOW,M.RUMP WILL
BE TOLD ABOUT TH
RESOURCES DO AS WELL ENTER OU HO
HOW IST GOIN PLAOU A SECURITSTA'
WHEN TRUMP SOC
MEDIA YI READYU OFHAAIANCE OF Jt
OR
TH'VT OFHIHAVECONNECTIONASE.APN.
THAT'S W
DOWN T
'RTO HAVE
IT THEMA
THEY'LL BE
>> DAVIDROCIATE S.PRIA RDI
THEAL
COURTHOUSE. QUESTION OF S
TWEG
SO FAR?
>> Reporter: WE KNOW HE'LL MAKE
TRN TO MIAMI.
SOME OF MY
WE C ET THEY'LHA
DOWN THERETH O THATERSTATE THE S
LA P IN SOME LORE
ALSO AS FAR OURT, THER
OME TYPE OF PERIMETER SET
ONLY PROTESTER BUT
WELL.
W BE A NAD
SECRET SERVICEE MIAMI POCEE ETT
AS WELL.EYIDTHREATRE AT THE MIA.
TH DFIND AREBL
LOOKING FOR Y NTE
O ON.
THEY WANY SITUATION RE AT THE O.
ENFCEONE OTNOTE, VICTOR, THIS .
AINLY GOING TOTOIME ON
THERE'A T OF HERE.
L TAKE HIM IHE BACK DOORS WHERL
FOR HIARRAIGNMENT.VICTOR?
YE BEEN SINSOME OF THE TRTERS
TH
WHATEN HEARI?eporteENT THE
LAST COUPLE OFS AT KING TF
SUOR
DO NOTELIEVE TT THE PHT HAY CLAS
D THEMT WAMENT YESTERDAY, AND I
SHOWED THEM THCTURESLE SHOWEHEN